I would like to invite Her Excellency
Ursula Thunder lion president of the
European Commission
the EU is implementing its green deal is
there anything more the UA the EU can do
to accelerate climate action both at
home and abroad
now we have 70 days and then the world
will meet in Dubai
expectation patients increase
as temperatures rise
so we have to become concrete and I
would like to speak about three topics
it's Ambitions its targets and its
finance and investment
first on ambition we have to better
protect our citizens especially the most
vulnerable ones against the loss and
damage that climate change brings
we need to agree on effective Solutions
still this year
the European Union will be a strong Ally
in those discussions
but at the same time
we should also show ambition in reducing
greenhouse gas emissions so we should go
faster in removing the root causes of
climate change
the European Union has set ambitious
emission reduction goals for 2030.
we want to reduce greenhouse gas
emissions by 55 at least and the good is
we are on track to overshoot this goal
already
but similar ambition is needed by other
major in emitters to ensure that Global
emissions Peak by 2025 and animated
fossil fuels are phased out well before
2050.
my second topic targets we have to
propel the global clean energy
transition
and therefore together with cup 28
President Sultan al-jabbar with
President Ruto of Kenya prime minister
Mia Motley of Barbados and others we're
building a Global Coalition so that by
cop 28 the whole world can agree on
tripling renewable energy
and doubling annual Energy savings by
2030. we need these Global goals because
only what gets measured gets done
and finally on finance and investment
more investment is needed especially in
developing countries with a huge
potential for renewable energy clean
hydrogen and critical raw materials and
that was also the message of the African
climate Summit you just heard president
Ruto
Europe has heard this message
in the next five years alone we will
invest at least 4 billion euros in
renewable energy and hydrogen in
developing economies as part of our 300
billion Euro global gateway plan
and this brings me to my last point and
this was just mentioned we need to
prompt investments before we meet in
Dubai we have to meet the 100 billion
dollar climate Finance goal indeed it is
a question of trust the European Union
will contribute its fair share of 27
billion dollars as we did the last years
more is needed for finance we want to
support the establishment of green Bond
markets in the Long Middle income
countries
Europe strongly supports a reform of
International Financial Financial system
and we will work with you Secretary
General I heard you end with interested
countries
to have at least 60 percent of global
emissions covered by carbon pricing by
2030. today it's only 23 that are
covered and this brings Revenue already
of 95 billion dollars so just imagine we
could cover 60 of global greenhouse gas
emissions the amount of revenues that we
would get to invest in low and middle
income countries these proposals are
concrete they are realistic let's use
the coming coming 70 days to turn them
into reality thank you
thank you